images qu'est-ce qui s'est passé avec
ces images elles étaient chez eux et ils
les ont donné eux-mêmes comme ça sans
vous demander c'est ça mon cher Cyril
depuis 2 ans et demi mes avocats
essayent de récupérer mon film parce que
le le le producteur ne veut pas me les
rendre alors justement on a le tweet de
de Anthony Dufour qui dit il n'y a
aucune image de an max dans le
complément d'enquête sur Gérard pardieu
ce film donne la parole à des femmes
courageuses regardez-le et si an max
veut mettre son propre film en ligne
bonne idée très bien donc il il entend
par là que j'ai sans doute pas de propre
film à montrer je vous ai apporté en
exclusive
Cyr un un message un sms que je crois
que la production enfin la régie va
envoyé voilà signé d'Antony Dufour le 15
novembre 2022 Yan je suis en train de
parler de toi et du film de GG donc le
fameux violeur parce que là on est en
2022 il l'appelle GG on se fait une
projection privé avec GG un de ses jours
on a plein d'idées c'est signé Anthony
Dufour c'est bizarre qu'il appelle GG en
2022 contrairement à moi en 2018 quand
je fais mon film Anthony Dufour sait
quelles sont les accusations qui pèsent
sur Gérard pardieu et bien en 2022 il y
a un an pile Anthony Dufour d' carie qui
est le Zoro des femmes violées et
celui-là même qui veut se faire une
petite projo avec GG j'ai rien d'utre à
rajouter c'est tout pour vous je
répondrai à des questions s'il en a par
que c'est intéressant ce que dit quand
même justement donc mais quand il dit
qu'il y a aucune image de votre film
c'est pas vrai il y en a et il y en a
d'autres
qui les IM off qu'on a vu hier don
l'image qui qui qui choque beaucoup vous
allez comprendre C c'est très bête quand
vous faites un un un film de fiction
vous dites action moteur la scène
s'arrête et ensuite les gens déconnent
quand vous filmez 24 heur sur 24 il y a
pas de action moteur donc les gens
déconnent parce qu'il y a pas de prise
en tant que tel ex dans 100 % des films
du cinéma français vous prenez les
conneries que disent les acteurs entre
les prises c'est du n'importe quoi et je
vais dire autre chose qui n'engage que
moi j'aimerais qu'un PS me prouve pour
l'instant Gérard a peut-être violé
peut-être pas on n pas la justice n'a
pas encore tranché et moi je prends
toujours la défense des femmes et je ne
pense pas qu'il y a de mythomanes chez
les femmes mais je vais vous dire une
chose j'aimerais qu'on me prouve qu'il y
a un lien de cause à effet mécanique
psychologique entre quelqu'un qui fait
des blagues inadmissibles et un il y a
des violeurs qui parlent très bien des
femmes et il y a des gros Pors qui font
des blagues toute la journée qui n'ont
jamais abusé d'une femme y a aussi des
grosorts qui vient il y a tous
les y a gros il y a des gros ports qui
il y a des gros ports qui ne vient pas
il y a des gros ports il y a des non
gros ports qui et des non gros pororts
qui ne pas les qu qure figures sont
évidemment existent dans la nature et
vous avez vu le portrait vous a pas
choqué vous l'avez pas trouvé réignon
vous l'avez pas trouvé g parce que vous
avez pas vous arrêtez pas de parler de
votre œuvre voler pas vol B ouais c'est
le sujet mais en fait moi j'estime que
vous pourriez être aussi content qu'on
voit un portrait jusqu'à je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure que si on m'avait demandé
et assez complaisant de votre part
d'ailleurs parce que vous seriez
beaucoup quand il
est vous AZ il y a un contexte c'est
sans doute ce qu'il avait dit de moins
chocant avec parce qu'il tous les jours
tous les jours tous les jours il y avait
inflation des blagues que ce que je veux
vous dire Géraldine parce que il faut
quand même vous compreniez la situation
je veux bien donner mes images si on me
les demande le problème c'est que on est
allé dans mon disque dur on est allé
dans les affaires on dit tiens ça va s'
servir je vous promets que je n'aurais
pas fait de rétention d'image si on me
les avait demandé j'aurais dit Anthony
du four vas-y ce que je ne supporte pas
c'est qu'on me les ait volé vous pouvez
l'entendre vous l'zis quand mais hier
non seulement j'ai au début géraline je
pensais que mon producteur avait vendu
les images ou don les images à
complément d'enquête et ça m'a pas
choqué parce que je me suis dit bon à la
limite c'est peut-être pour servir une
cause mais ce qui est fou c'est que j'ai
appris qu'il était réalisateur et
producteur du sujet et là il y a un abus
de confiance contre moi les images vous
croyez franchement vous me connaissez je
crois un peu vous croyez que j'aurais
fait de la rétention si les images
pouvaient être bénéfiques pour dénoncer
quoi que ce soit JIS de la vie quand les
aut par moi j'ai une question sur la
manière dont le vol s organisé parce
qu'il y a deux possibilités soit dès
2018 ce producteur réalisateur s'est dit
tiens je vais piéger Yan moi c'est
gerérard pardieu soit là il s'est dit
tiens avec ce que j'ai comme Rush qui
sont accablants insupportables de Gérard
pardieux je vais pouvoir faire un
complément d'enquête C r vous avez
raison sur les deux cas c'est que je
pense qu'au début il voulait vraiment
produire mon film parce que je voulais
sortir ça au cinéma Gérard était attaqué
de rien du tout en 2018 ça c'est
important de le dire Géraldine et moi je
vais vous dire un truc Géraldine si j'ai
enlevé images de mon film c'est parce
que je l'ai trouvé insupportable et
c'est pas l'histoire que je voulais
raconter je voulais raconter un monstre
sacré du cinéma là-bas on l'appelle Jean
valgan et la Corée du Nord donc moi
j'étais gêné je voulais pas montrer ça
un film n'est pas
fait je rép non je répond à c'est
insultant pour je rép à
question respecte respecte les questions
des
aut question Gill ce qui a dû se passer
mon cher Gill c'est que au début je
pense qu'il voulait produire mon
long-métrage et quand il a vu qu'il y
avait des accusations sur Gérard il
s'est dit on ne pourra plus jamais
sortir un film avec Gérard pardieu au
cinéma donc le jour où la situation va
s'aggraver je vais mais pourquoi est-ce
qu'il m'en a pas parlé j'aurais très
bien pu le réaliser moi le complément
d'enquête pourquoi il l'a fait derrière
mon dos c'est tout ce que je dénonce
parce que la cause est bonne on va pas
se mentir jaces cardos quand si vous
avez vous avez été euh voilà dans
les ce cas peut se présenter on en
parlait tout à l'heure avec Yan il y a
quelque chose moi qui me trouble alors
d'abord je redis ce que j'ai dit hier
évidemment que le contenu des phrases
prononcées par Gérard pardieu est
évidemment inadmissible et notamment ce
qu'il dit à l'endroit de cette jeune
fille qu'il sexualise de façon
absolument abominable mais on est sur un
on est sur un débat de moral par rapport
à votre
droit moral concernant ces imag de tous
les arties de ce pays c'est important de
savoir que
on l'artiste est propriétaire moralement
de ses images ou de ses œuvres ou de ses
écrits et de sa musique il est témoin
aussi de quelque chose d'amoral géradine
l'un n'empâchait pas l'autre en réalité
c'està-dire que auraits bien pu lu avait
demandé il les aurit don il aurait très
bien pu faire son film il faut pas
oublier que j'essaie de les récupérer
depuis 4 ans ces images 2020 mais vous
auriez pu en parler vous avez vous avez
quand même un pouvoir médiatique
incroyable vous savez très bien vous
avez des tribunes partout sur les
plateaux dans les journaux vous pouvez
dire moi j'ai filmé un truc de de par
qui a gerbé regardez RZ alors a eu des
plaines a des ples
DEP je voulais dire je voulais dire
juste une chose c'est que lorsque
l'équipe se déplace parce qu'elle est
sensibilisée à un matériel qui est
incroyable c'est naturel qu'elle aille
voir et qu'elle aille vérifier et en
général c'est la base on vérifie
toujours les circonstances comment ça a
été filmé qui a filmé et donc on en
parlait tout à l'heure avec y moi je ne
veux pas faire de procès d'intention du
tout mais c'est impossible que l'équipe
n''est pas compris que ça c'était fait
et que y moi c'était là au moins et
qu'il filmait bah oui mais voilà donc il
y a quand même quelque chose qui est un
peu troublant mais d'un point de vue
légal après je sais pas je veux augurer
de rien mais d'un point de vue légal ça
appartient au producteur mais le
producteur ne peut rien faire sans
l'auteur c'est une espèce de couple qui
peut pas se défaire donc ça déjà de ce
point de vue-l normalement c'est illégal
mais j'ai envie de dire illégal
moralement c'estd que à un moment donné
Anthony Dufour il doit quand même poser
la question à yanx de savoir s'il veut
bien libérer une partie des rush pour la
bonne cause puisque effectivement
làdessus je suis tout à fait d'accord
sur le fond c'est qu'il y a des éléments
qui apportent quelque chose au contexte
aujourd'hui compte tenu des plaintes qui
sont prononcées contre Monsieur de
depuis 2020 moi j'ai une question vous
comment en tant qu'humain quand vous
regardez ce qu'il dit même si vous dites
que c'est TR qu minutes comment vous
pouvez continuer la collaboration parce
que moi quand je garde ça pour moi c'est
une fin de carrière parce que je vois ça
moi j'ai pas envie de regarder des films
de quelqu'un qui a des propos comment
vous donc humain vous continuez très
bonne question et je vais vous expliquer
ce qui s'est passé on est en Corée du
Nord je suis pour pour 10 jours dans une
dictature dont on ne peut pas s'en aller
il y a il y a un avion toutes les
semaines je tourne avec Gérard à
l'époque Gérard est toujours en 2018
c'est important de le savoir il est
toujours celui qui habite toute sa vie
dans un film qui s'appelle les valseuses
il n'est jamais sorti des valseuses il
fait des blagues grasses sur tout ce qui
bouge non stop il le fait depuis 30 40
50 ans c'est ces blagues grâces qui ne
me font pas rire on a le droit de rire
ou pas d'une blague grâce pour moi j'ai
enlevé les pire parce qu'elles me sont
insupportables tout seul de dans ma
chambre tout seul j'ai pas besoin de 15
personnes pour me dire c'est pas bien si
vous voulez ces mêmes blagues qui sont
insupportables lorsqu'elle rentre en
résonance avec des accusations de viol
c'est même plus une blague pas drôle ou
pas c'est quelque chose qui vient
signifier qui vient signifier ce n'est
plus quelqu'un qui se comporte mal et
qui fait des blagues insupportables
c'est quelqu'un qui tout d'un coup
peut-être nous offre une lecture sur ce
qu'il est vraiment donc ce n'est plus le
le si vous voulez mon film change de
statut il se métamorphose il est
gangrainé par quelque chose et c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai décidé de ne
pas le sortir j'aurais trouvé indcent je
voulais le sortir en salle j'ai trouvé
indécent par rapport à la parole des
victimes de sortir ce film je me suis
dit et bien j'ai fait un film pour rien
il ne sortira jamais c'est mon choix
j'avais décidé de ne jamais le sortir ce
que j'ai fait Géraldine je l'ai montré
une petite centaine de personnes j'ai vu
votre vidéo parce que je voulais avoir
des retours c'était catastrophique enfin
ou c'est norm dommage c'est dommage
parce que je vais vous dire une chose cy
après je me tais il y avait des passages
vraiment c'est dommage que ça soit abîmé
évidemment par des Vanes grâce et il y
avait des passages sur la Corée du Nord
qui ét extraordinaire vous dites vous
dites vous parlez de Van grâce il y a
des choses a des paroles qui sont
pénalement
répréhensible de la j'ai dit
insupportableou voilà auinupportable
c'estd que pénalement ce sont des on
appelle ça alors
uneoc l'outrage sexiste c'est depuis
c'est la loi Chiapa d'août 2018 si c'est
dans mon film et si ça n'y'est pas
justement et là concernant la petite
fille qui a 10 ans c'est l'outrage
sexiste aggravé qui est un délit
maintenant qui date du 1ier c'est en
vigueur depuis le 1er avril 2023 donc
quoi qu'il en soit il ne peut pas être
poursuivi pour ça puisque la loi pénale
plus sévère n'est pas rétroactive en
revanche concernant parce que finalement
il y a trois problèmes les dont il est
accusé il est présumé innocent il y a
pas de débat là-dessus c'est à la
justice de trancher le vol de vos vidéos
et l'outrage c'est seiste il y a trois
ce sont les trois problèmes l'outrage
sexiste il n'a pas été condamné les
viols pour l'instant il n'a pas été
condamné et vous pour le vol de vos
vidéo c'est encore une autre difficulté
mais si on enlève la morale même si
c'est difficile d'un point de vue
juridique rien ne l'empêche de tourner
encore dans d'autres film puisquen droit
il n'existe pas de peine d'inéligibilité
cinématographique il existe des peines
d'inéligibilité pour se présenter à une
élection on l'a vu sur certains
politiques mais d'un point de vue
cinématographique si des producteurs
réalisateurs j'en doute mais s'ils ont
envie de tourner avec lui ils peuvent le
faire vous pouvez vous pouvez les
attaquer pour ben je vais les attaquer
ça va coûter très cher d'abord il y a un
abus de confiance et puis c'est un vol
je suis propriétaire de ces images j'ai
d'ailleurs je sais pas si vous venez
Cyril il y a très longtemps je vous
avais dit j'ai un film avec Gérard pardu
encoreor est-ce que ça vous dit de le
produire vous avez dit je verrai on n
pas eu le temps mais si je vous avais
posé cette question c'est que déjà à
l'époque j'avais un problème avec ce
producteur et c'était en 2020 il ne
voulait pas me rendre ces imagesc et
maintenant ce que je voudrais vous dire
aussi pourquoi il a produit alors pensz
bah parce que il a il s'est fait à mon
avis beaucoup d'argent en donner ça en
donnant ça à complément d'enquête j'ai
jamais gagné un centime sur le fil
complément d'enquête à payé les images
je suis pas sûr non mais je pense qu'il
a été payé pour faire le film ah ou il é
payé pour faire le film estce que moi
j'ai jamais été payé pour faire ce film
et on a il est un peu bête d'une
certaine manière Anthony Dufour parce
que j'ai des centaines de mail avec mes
avocats où il essae de me vendre ce film
pour 68000 € en disant voilà ça te
coûtera temps et cetera donc mon film
existe et là où je rejoins Géraldine il
y a un truc moral sur le film c'est pas
parce que je voulais le récupérer que je
voulais le sortir je voulais avoir la
possibilité d'être propriétaire de ces
images et euh j'ai même cru un moment
que j'allais faire une projection de 7h
avec en mettant le Maxim parce qu'il y a
des temps longs et tout ça et donc je
trouve dommage qu'on ne puisse pas voir
un documentaire qui à mon avis est
exceptionnel sur le pays Corée du Nord
mais ça c'est la faute de Gérard là pour
le coup c'est pas la faute d'Antony du
four s'il a eu des propos comme ça je
veux dire moi j'ai plus envie non plus
de sortir juste sur les propos même pas
sur les actes je n'ai plus envie de avec
les propos il y a il y a 5 ans je
j'aurais peut-être hésité mais les
propos de la petite fille avec les viol
il y a plus de question le film ne
sortira jamais donc ça c'est mort c'est
fini j'ai fait un film pour rien parce
que la morale ça existe c'est tout merci
y max merci à tous en tout cas d'avoir
été avec nous tout de suite c'est le son
de la viille